Let me give you another algebraic
interpretation of principal components,
and eventually this will
just get us to our formulas.
Here we have our point P, and
let's supposed we have some origin.
If we want to minimize the square of
the distance from the point to a line,
we want to find the line
to minimize this square.
Well, you remember Pythagoreans Theorem,
of course you do, right.
It's that the sum of the squares of
the two legs of a right triangle
are equal to the square
of the hypotenuse.
If we want to minimize the square
distance of the point to that line
we can, the same thing as maximizing the
projection of that point on the line.
That's what this value is here, right?
X transpose P.
X is some unit vector through
the origin, and if we project P
on to it that's going to be the vector
and you want to maximize that length.
So minimizing the sum of the squares,
the distance to the line is the same
thing as maximizing the sum of the
squares, the projections on that line.
A way of writing that is we
want to sum up all the squares.
And this is just a little bit of
a matrix manipulation trick, right?
If I wrote my points down here right,
of x1, y1 or x2, y2.
And if this was my line so
it's maybe, it's, A, B, right,
if I multiply x transpose b transpose,
so now this is B, xy, xy, bx, all right?
If you multiply that all through,
what you'll realize is,
it's exactly that value, okay?
It's the sum over all the points of
that square of the magnitude, all right?
So.
What that means is algebraically,
this maximizing the projected distance,
can be written like this, right.
So our goal is to maximize x transpose,
b transpose, bx.
But we've got a constraint, right.
X is a unit vector.
So that means that x
transpose x has to equal 1.
So what we have to do is we have to
maximize this subject to a constraint.
All right, so
that's what this says here.
And I wrote is as m.
Maximize equal to x transpose mx.
Where m is b transpose b.
So we just have a single matrix.
Now, I'm not going to tell
you a lot about this method.
But I am going to introduce this quick
notion of what's called Lagrange
multipliers.
Here is e and here is e prime.
And you notice that what we
added to e prime is this term,
lambda times 1 minus x transpose x.
So Megan,
if everything is solved correctly,
1 minus x transpose x should be what?
>> Zero?
>> Whoa!
Yes, zero.
So, when this thing is solved correctly,
it doesn't matter what this lambda is,
right?
Because it will add zero to the term.
That in a very hand wavy way, that is
the method of Legrange multipliers.
It says, I'm going to put in a term
Multiplied by lambda that will
be zero at the correct solution.
And then, you solve everything and
you've satisfied your,
Lagrange multiplier method.
It turns out in our
case it's even easier.
So that's our e prime.
So, what we do now is, we take the
derivative of that new error function,
e prime with respect to x,
and we get this.
2 Mx plus 2 lambda x is the derivative.
And, now, in order to minimize this
we set this equal to what, Megan?
>> Zero,
>> Zero, very good.
We actually rehearsed
that one this time.
And so when you do that, you get
this very simple equation that says,
Mx equals lambda x, alright.
Forget the positive or
negative, doesn't matter because lambda
can go in either direction, all right?
So that's a very special x, right?
So when I multiply x by a matrix M,
if I get back a linear multiplier,
in this case lambda, of x, that means
x is an eigenvector of the matrix M.
So that means that x is going to be
an eigenvector of this B transpose B.
All right?
So, this axis of least inertia.
This solution where we minimize
the distance to the axes.
The sum of the square distances,
which is the same as
maximizing the distance along.
Says it has something
to do with this matrix,
b transpose b, where b was
that list of all those points.